mon invité aujourd'hui pour un entretien
exceptionnel c'est vous vanessa n'a qu'à
tes bons jours
bienvenue sur ce plateau merci de
prendre le temps de répondre à nos
questions vous avez 25 ans vous êtes
ougandaise militante écologiste l'un des
visages de ceux qu'on appelle la
génération
climat je voudrais qu'on regarde deux
images vanessa n'a quitté pour commencer
entre ces deux images à peine trois ans
se sont écoulés
sur la deuxième vous manifestez seul à
kampala en ouganda pour alerter sur
l'urgence climatique en afrique et sur
la seconde vous fait la une du magazine
time que s'est il passé pour vous entre
ces deux images
la photo je suis devant le parlement de
ganta c'était une des toutes premières
manifestations ou des grèves
qui ont été menées en ouganda pour le
climat et ce qui s'est passé au cours de
cette période
jusqu'à la seconde photographie celle où
je figure sur la photo de l'oeuvre sur
la couverture de time magazine c'est que
j'ai organisé des manifestations dans la
rue que j'ai fait appel à beaucoup de
sources pour les communautés pour leur
faire comprendre l'urgence du climat je
vais utiliser toutes les plates formes
ce qui était à ma disposition pour
parler de la crise climatique parce que
je pense qu'il est important de
communiquer sur ce qui se passe
réellement mais aussi de communiquer
éventuelle solution pour la planète ce
sont les populations les plus
vulnérables et les moins responsables
qui sont les premières victimes du
réchauffement de la planète c'est ça
l'injustice que vit aujourd'hui
l'injustice climatique que vit
aujourd'hui le continent africain
c'est une des réalités assez horrible de
cette crise climatique que ceux qui sont
les plus infectés maintenant ce sont les
moins responsables de la crise par
exemple
dans le passé le continent africain
on représente moins de 3 ou 4 % des
émissions mondiales alors que c'est le
continent africain qui en souffrent des
conséquences et plus doit
cyclone toutes sortes de désastre
climatique sur le continent nous avons
vu des orages tropicaux affecter les
gens en particulier dans le sud du
continent nous avons vu des sécheresses
extrêmes des inondations dans l'afrique
de l'est la crise climatique sur le
continent africain est quelque chose qui
se produit
alors que nous nous battons pour limiter
le réchauffement climatique à 1,5 à 1,2
degré de réchauffement et les gens
paient déjà
leurs exploitations agricoles
l'électricité les écoles entre toute
leur vie est menacée ni détruites c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale de l'eau
c'est un bon exemple de cette urgence
sur le continent africain alors qu'un
africain sur trois aujourd'hui manque
d'eau
bon jeu
l'importance de l'eau
le continent africain est ailleurs
partout ailleurs d'ailleurs visible
guinée avec certains des projets qui
nous voyons se mettre en place ceci
pourrait être délétère pour l'eau
potable on voit par exemple dans aïda n1
l'afrique de l'est est en train où va
traverser le bassin de lacq de tauriac
évidemment c'est un bassins hydriques
qui fait vivre plus de 4 millions de
personnes dans l'afrique de l'est et pas
seulement en ouganda fait pour l'eau
pour l'alimentation et nous avons vu la
réduction qui est source hydrique est
celle du lac tchad et ça a créé des
conflits dans la région donc c'est vrai
qu il y a un grand besoin et grande
urgence pour nous de protéger dans
sources d'eau
et pour cela il faut des fonds pour
mettre un terme à tous les éléments qui
abîme dans son cidre hic il faut aider
les pays en développement à s'adapter
aux impacts du dérèglement climatique
mais ça ne suffit pas dit vous les pays
riches et responsables doivent payer
payer pour quoi faire
tout à fait les pays
du monde doivent payer mon la crise
climatique parce que nous et qui a causé
la crise climatique nous savons qu'il
doit payer et des pays comme le mien
sont déjà en train de souffrir des
pertes des dégâts à cause du
réchauffement climatique on peut pas
s'adapter éternellement à l'extinction
à la fin la perte nos cultures maire de
notre identité ou la perte de notre
histoire et les changements climatiques
cause beaucoup des éléments précités
c'est pour ça que nous devons mettre en
place un fonds pour compenser la perte
nous avons besoin d'un financement pour
la médication des effets et le
financement de réparation pour les
pertes les leaders dans la perse
privatives ou le réchauffement
climatique doivent comprendre que c'est
pour nous maintenant tout de suite que
vous vous plaidé aussi pour que
l'afrique est un modèle qui ne soit pas
celui qui a été choisi par les pays du
nord et qui les a menés vers cette
responsabilité climatique qu'elle l'ait
ce modèle est ce qu'il est
économiquement viable
oui
à mon avis le développement économique
c'est
être considéré que comme un
développement s'ils créent du bienfait
et une amélioration pour la planète et
pour la population mais si le
développement économique est équivalent
à 1 destruction de nos ressources en eau
de notre terre et de la pollution que ce
soit par le pétrole ou le charbon ou le
gaz ça ne peut pas être considérée comme
un développement économique s'il ya une
possibilité pour la nation africaine de
passer un développement durable d'avoir
une transition équitable est laissée aux
permettre aux gens de sortir de la
pauvreté c'est ça que nous voulons
beaucoup de grands groupes comme total
projette d'état chose à des gens dans
mon pays par exemple ils disent que des
grands projets vont fournir des emplois
vont apporter la prospérité économique à
la population mais nous avons vu comment
des pays en afrique australe où les
extractions pétrole
ont déjà été installées ces états se
trouvent encore dans la pauvreté ça veut
dire que les profits sont donc rapatrié
vers le pays d'origine du coup j'ai
alors que la pollution reste dans des
pays comme le nôtre hui les avantages
économiques retourne au porteur du
projet donc nous devons permettre aux
pays africains de passer vers l'énergie
renouvelable qui permettra à sortir les
gens de la pauvreté vous êtes en france
depuis quelques jours vous l'avez évoqué
à l'instant pour alerter sur les dangers
d'un immense projet pétrolier
effectivement mené par le groupe
français total en plein coeur d'un parc
naturel qui a le projet qui a le soutien
du gouvernement notamment de votre pays
et qui menacent vous l'avais dit à
l'instant la vie quotidienne de millions
de personnes est ce que vous avez été
entendues notamment par les députés
français
ouais l'âme et bien pourquoi nous avons
déjà parlé
de personnes durant notre voyage enfance
et ils nous ont testé
et surtout les gens qui sont prêts à se
battre à nos côtés nous avons parlé à
certains députés qui ont écouté ce que
nous a fait un dirait qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient se battre à nos côtés
mais nous devons entendre ce qu'il a à
dire le président mâcon nous voulons
savoir quelle est sa position quand il
s'agit de ce projet de savoir quelle est
sa position quand il s'agit des gens qui
habitent la planète et les pays en
question quand je vais à se développer
est ce qu'il va
pareil pour soutenir les gens cassent ou
est ce qui va soutenir les porteurs de
projets parce que avant que la
construction du projet ne commence le
voyons déjà les impacts du projet il ya
des milliers de personnes qui ont été
déplacées déjà plus de 80000 personnes
déplacées à cause de ce projet
ce projet va traverser beaucoup de
rivières est en plein coeur d'un des
plus anciens parcs nationaux en ouganda
menaces différentes espèces animales va
traverser le lac victoria
d'autres là encore donc tous ces
éléments naturels et toute cette
biodiversité est mise à risque à cause
du projet
donc nous espérons que alors que nous
arrivons à la fin notre voyage que les
gens en france vont continuer à nous
soutenir même lorsque nous serons
reparti et nous espérons surtout que le
gouvernement français va nous soutenir
et va être un vrai leader sur des
questions climatiques parce que c'est
plus que des belles déclarations non
c'est juste il faut
que les mots soient suivies d'actions et
nous allons voir ceci du président
maquereau en grâce il dira que ce projet
ne va pas bénéficier ni les gens ni la
planète et pour l'instant il n'est pas
ce leader sur le climat qui dit être à
vos yeux
il n'est pour l'instant pas le leader en
pointe sur les questions climatiques
qu'il prétend être
et bien d'après ce que je sais le
président macron soutient ce projet
parce que il a écrit à notre président
est la seule chose qui me permettra de
croire qu'il est un leader sur les
questions climatiques c'est s'il change
d'avis sur ce projet j'ai aussi entendu
par certains amis que les conversations
sur le climat
sont minimales maintenant cours des
élections présidentielles durant cette
période ce qui est frustrant très
frustrant je crois que toutes les côtes
où les candidats aux élections
présidentielles et tous ceux qui veulent
devenir président en france doit avoir
ses discussions sur les questions
climatiques et les médias et les
journalistes doivent leur poser des
questions sur le climat nous devons
avoir une conversation sur le programme
climatiques du président depuis cinq ans
vanessa n'a quitté que vous vous engagez
pour le climat comment est ce que vous
sentez les choses avancer ou d'ailleurs
est ce qu'elle n'avance pas
ça fait ça tout à fait c'est un comble
mais d'après ce que j'ai vu
le pouvoir des gens nous montre que nous
pouvons faire changer les choses que
nous pouvons transformer le monde pourra
mieux donc à partir du moment où j'ai
commencé à marcher pour le climat nous
voyons que les choses changent et que il
y a beaucoup de sensibilisation qui en a
découlé j'en demande la justice
climatique mais parfois c'est très
triste de voir qu'alors que nous les
gens allant dans la bonne direction nos
dirigeants ne vont pas dans la bonne
direction avec des décisions qu'ils
prennent mais nous n'allons pas
abandonner parce que si nous avons tous
non alors il va abandonner notre planète
rêves et notre existence l'accès à
l'information sur ces sujets est un
enjeu majeur pour les jeunes et
peut-être pour les jeunes africains en
particulier vous le savez bien parce qu
en ouganda manifesté pour le climat ont
manifesté tout court d'ailleurs peut
vous valoir d'être emprisonnés
oui en particulier sur ce projet ci dont
je viens de parler nous avons certains
de nos collègues qui sont des défenseurs
de l'environnement qui y ont été arrêtés
simplement pour avoir parlé du projet
ont vu certains de nos confrères qui ont
été menacés on leur a dit que s'il
continuait d'évoquer le projet ils
seraient renvoyés
de leur poste de travail donc il y a
tellement de choses à défendre et que
les activistes - l'ouganda c'est pour ça
que c'est important d'obtenir le soutien
de la france
parce que beaucoup
de mes collègues ont vu que il parlait
de ce projet mais il n'y avait pas
d'action donc il faut que la france
soutienne la population autre chose qui
m'est arrivé lorsque j'étais d'exemple
mans c'est que j'ai vu que la france est
le pays des droits de l'homme en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on m'a dit je ne m'en
suis pas sur mais bon la france est
censée défendre les droits de l'homme
né le harcèlement
des
manifestants et quelque chose qui est
courant donc je crois que la france
devrait prendre position sur ce projet
vous allez rencontrer
mercredi au vatican le pape le chef de
l'église catholique
qu'allez vous lui demandez où lui dire
ce que je vais lui dire ce que je veux
dire
c'est une surprise ça va être une
surprise pour vous tous
mais j'espère très sincèrement que le
pape nous soutiendra
nous nous sommes tournés vers les
différents dirigeants du monde et
et nous disent toujours que nous sommes
une inspiration pour tous et que nous
allons changer le monde mais dire aux
jeunes qu'ils sont une inspiration pour
tous ce n'est pas suffisant donc
maintenant nous allons nous tourner vers
les dirigeants spirituels et leur
demander de nous soutenir parce qu'au
bout du compte c'est une lutte pour la
création ces subsides pour la création
de dieu ce sera ma dernière question
dans votre lutte dans votre combat il y
a beaucoup d'espoir pour l'avenir
d'air has to be il faut qu'ils aient de
l'espoir
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'espoir il n'y
a pas de désir de se battre s'il n'y a
pas d'espoir alors on ne peut pas avoir
de vision de ce pour quoi on se bat donc
je crois en tout état de cause il faut
garder espoir même quand on est frustré
il faut continuer à croire nous devons
nous mettre
dans une position dans laquelle les ce
poids représente une force parce que
nous croyons qu'un autre monde est
possible et pas seulement nécessaire
pour nous tous mais possible et qu'on
peut le faire advenir merci beaucoup
merci manet saana caté d'être venu ce
matin sur le plateau de france 24
très bon voyage à vous en italie et à
très bientôt ici en france